wednesday edition of pft pm pft live
still off until july 20. it is the first
day of july and we are four weeks away
from the
scheduled launch of training camp we'll
talk about the various issues of the day
that are relevant to the ongoing
coronavirus pandemic and the national
football league before i get to that
it's important to note
two weeks from today is the deadline for
signing franchise tag players to
long-term contracts and that's the
deadline
whether or not the player has signed his
franchise tender it's the deadline also
for kenyan drake the cardinals running
back who was subject to the transition
tag and he has signed that tag july 15
long-term deal
has to be done by then otherwise no new
contract can be signed until after
the end of the upcoming regular season
or more accurately only a one-year deal
can be signed in theory in theory a
player can get different terms than what
the franchise tender would promise for
example a commitment that perhaps next
year the franchise tag would not be used
that's happened in the past that could
happen with one of the various players
who have not yet signed their franchise
tag but may
use the unsigned tag as leverage to get
that term if there isn't a long-term
deal by july 15. so two weeks from now
there will be news or not regarding the
various players with the franchise tag
one of those players who is subject to
the july 15 deadline for a long-term
deal chief's defensive lineman chris
jones
said on social media on tuesday
basically
if i don't get a long-term deal i'm not
signing the tender and i'm going to sit
out the season
i've spoken to le'veon bell
bell is the guy who sat on the 2018
season now
there's a difference in sitting out all
of the second season of the franchise
tender versus the first season of the
franchise tender if chris jones sits out
all of this season he can still be
tagged next year at a 20 increase over
what the tag was this year if you sit
out all of the second year
of the franchise tag the following year
the only way to retain the players
rights via the franchise tag is to give
him that quarterback offer the five
highest cap numbers in the league the
average of those cap numbers becomes the
franchise tender for that third season
something that no one is ever going to
do with a non-quarterback most likely
there may be some exception at some
point some transcendent player who just
gets a sack on every play or something
along those lines for the most part
though teams aren't going to use the
third franchise tender on anyone but a
quarterback and even on a quarterback
you're looking at a 44 bump over the
second tag so long story bearable if
you're gonna sit out the full season
it's better to do it in the second year
of the tag now chris jones needs to
remember a couple of things first of all
there's a lot of uncertainty in the
world right now one thing that is
certain is that offer that has been put
on the table and the promise of a 20
raise next year even if the salary cap
goes down 20 raised next year the only
way he doesn't get the 20 raised next
year is if there's some sort of
agreement between the league and the
union where the union for all franchise
tag players says well it won't be a 20
bump
in 2021 it'll be 10 or 15 or 5 or
something else that's the only way
that that goes away is if the
fundamental rules of the franchise tag
change
and i'm not suggesting they will i'm
just using that as an example of how it
could happen if there is some
negotiation or
the broader issues that are involved in
this effort to try to figure out how to
play during a pandemic and if there is
an agreement reached on how to deal with
a reduced franchise tag or salary cap
for next year that's a possibility
possibility not a probability
anyway at a time when there is so much
that is
impossible to figure out the smart move
would be to go ahead and take that
franchise tag play it out this year take
the 20 raise next year and then if you
have to go year to year for two seasons
after that second year
it's going to be very difficult for the
chiefs to use the franchise tag
a third time the most they would do is
transition tag a third time which would
be a 20 raise over
the second year franchise tag salary
which again would be a 20 bump over this
year the numbers go up very quickly so i
know chris jones wants that long-term
deal this isn't an ideal climate to get
a long-term deal and frankly you know
you got to make your decisions in light
of what the climate is the climate
suggests going year to year go year to
year it's still damn good money at a
time when many things are uncertain
another player who
wants to not sign his franchise tag not
signed a long-term deal not play for the
team that tagged him anymore yannick and
gaque there was a reporter today he
still wants to be traded and look i want
to be respectful to my colleagues in the
media who are reporting these things and
it's accurate it's truthful it's just
okay why would circumstances have
changed he's always wanted to be traded
i don't think he was going to wake up on
july one two weeks from the deadline for
doing a long term deal saying you know
what i don't want to be traded now now
that would be that would be news that
would be news if a guy who's made it
clear that he wants out all of a sudden
decides he doesn't want out of
jacksonville hi macy macy's barking
somebody's here anyway
yes and gawkway still wants out
and no the jaguars have yet to show any
inclination to trade him and the problem
is
with all the uncertainty that is
affecting teams financially the
possibility of cap going down in 2021
are you going to find a team that will
give the jaguars what they want for
yannick and gawkway and in turn given
gakwe what he wants by way of a
long-term contract i don't know that
that happens and i don't know if there's
a team out there that would just trade
for in gawkway
under the franchise tag and step into
jacksonville's shoes and be in a
position where next year they would own
a 20 raise over this year so
for some of the same reasons why it's
going to be difficult for jamal adams to
get a trade out of new york franchise
tag players this year i think are going
to encounter difficulty in getting a
trade done especially as we inch toward
this
area of uncertainty regarding
the virus and it feels like every day
the temperature is going up just a
little bit on the uncertainty and on the
possibility that the season will be
adjusted moved curtailed canceled we
don't know we don't know and i'm going
to start right there
there's a disconnect between what the
people at the upper reaches of the
league think about the virus
and
what everyone else
thinks believes suspects whether it's
players coaches fans media because the
people at the top of the league who have
a high degree of optimism that football
is going to be played this year have not
bothered to share with anyone else and
look the fans in the media would love to
know but i'd like to think players and
coaches have an even greater reason to
know
whether or not this is going to work how
it's going to work how it's going to
look how it's going to feel something
i've been talking about for a while now
with each passing day you get closer and
closer to training camp players need to
know
players need to know for a variety of
reasons they need to know what to expect
they need to know what kind of decisions
they're going to make for themselves and
their families more on that coming up in
a minute or two
but the bottom line is those folks who
have that high degree of optimism at the
top of the league be nice if they would
share with someone
specifics details reasons that would
allow other people to come to the
conclusion that yes football can't
happen in a pandemic period
more evidence to suggest it's going to
be difficult to pull off training camp
and this season just a couple of days
after arizona went back into not a full
shutdown but a shutdown of bars theaters
gyms etc for at least 30 days california
in 19 counties putting the clamps back
on a lot of these areas where people can
gather in a confined space and the virus
can spread so what will governor gavin
newsom do next i don't know
by the time we get to the end of july
will even be possible or plausible
to have training camps in california
cities or arizona or florida a lot can
happen in four weeks a lot has happened
in the last four weeks we were kind of
getting to a point where around memorial
day
that
we thought
maybe
these clouds are parting maybe we're
through the worst of it maybe it really
is going to subside until a second wave
potentially would come in october
november december
never happened
first wave never ended first wave is
just finally hitting other states now in
california they're getting a bit of a
boomerang effect because they were part
of that
first crisis group back in march and
april when it was washington california
and new york and connecticut
connecticut's got it figured out
connecticut went to very extreme
measures as it relates to mask wearing
i saw something today that their
hospitalizations are under 100 for the
coronavirus right now under 100.
so some of these other states need to
look at what the states are doing
that got it figured out and start doing
those things this isn't difficult folks
this isn't rocket science there's
evidence out there in some states as to
how they went about beating back this
crisis
do what they did
arizona california florida texas
hotbeds of the virus
and hubs of professional and college
football
time for them to start doing what they
did in connecticut what they did in new
york to beat this thing back or they're
not going to beat it back and as i said
yesterday
even if you don't care about yourself
even if you don't care about your family
members or your acquaintances to whom
you could give the virus
if you care about football and you want
to watch football wear a mask do what's
expected do what's required and here's
hoping that the government official out
there
in a given state who's responsible for
making those decisions or collectively
the politicians generally
warm up
aggressively to the idea of mask wearing
we're starting to see it it had been a
red state blue state thing for a while
more and more of the republican
politicians are telling people wear a
mask there's one in particular who could
go a long way towards sending that
message he hasn't and he won't and even
if he did at this point i don't know how
much of a difference it would make
an issue that i raised yesterday at
profootballtalk.com
something that i've picked up recently
and something peter king has been
talking about for a while the
possibility of teams traveling on game
days this year there are teams that are
thinking about it there's at least one
team that i know of that is planning to
do it for the first game of the season
packing up
getting on the plane and flying the day
of the game
not spending the night
no hotel stay
you take your stuff from the plane to
the stadium the players and the coaches
from the plane to the stadium
play the game pack it all up take it
back to the plane and get out of dodge
now it's not unprecedented back in 2012
the steelers did that when hurricane
sandy had hit hotel rooms were being
occupied by local residents the steelers
didn't want to be a drain on the system
so they flew up and back the same day to
play the giants and the students
actually won the game so it's not a a
guaranteed loss a lot of people
immediately look at this from a gambling
angle and say oh well hey the home team
is going to win bet the home team bet
the home team well the line will reflect
an actual or perceived bump for the home
team if the road team flew in that day
and maybe what happens is
the points that will go away for the
home team
by not having fans in the stands maybe
that gets restored by having an opponent
who travels on game day so you know the
loose rule of thumb is playing at home
is worth three points
you take away the fans that goes down
you make the not make the but you factor
in the road team traveling on game day
and then maybe it goes back to where it
was either way
it's being discussed
there were multiple players who reacted
to our tweet of that headline in a
negative way tyrant matthew said no
he's not interested in doing that hell
no he said
eric ebron of the steelers said the
whole team's going to end up on ninja
preserve other players with similar
reactions when we
put that out there that teams are indeed
thinking about talking about considering
the possibility of game day travel in
2020 and there are plenty of variables
that could just screw things up you get
a weather issue
you don't get there on time what happens
you get a
a maintenance issue with the plane how
many times have you sat on the tarmac
waiting and waiting and waiting for the
maintenance crew to show up and figure
out whatever it is reset a computer
remove a seat i've seen it all in the
past five years of flying back and forth
to new york on weekends and every once
in a while it's rare but every once in a
while i would do the early morning
flight from pittsburgh to one of the new
york airports on a sunday with the goal
of getting to the studio by noon and
being there for the full day of games
and then obviously be available for the
7pm eastern start of football night in
america and i'd be a nervous wreck until
the plane landed
nervous wreck
because it doesn't take much to screw
everything up and the next thing you
know you're late or you're hustling to
get there or you got a car that's coming
to pick you up or you're looking for a
train whatever you don't want to get in
that spot
and that's why you don't travel the day
of for something like that
now if there aren't fans at these games
okay well the game's supposed to start
at one i guess we'll start at four or
maybe it becomes a night game now it's
not fair to the home team
but you want to get the game in
maybe you have to move the game from a
sunday to a monday
again not fair to the home team but
they're going to want to get the games
in
because ultimately this entire approach
is about getting in the 256 regular
season games and making the money and i
don't fault them for that
i mean it's
it's easy to
to say america needs these games
but if we're being candid
the nfl needs these games because the
nfl needs and wants the money that comes
from these games especially when they're
going to give up the billions
potentially that would come from playing
games without fans
and when it comes to playing games with
fans there was report from daniel kaplan
in the athletic today
that
the nfl may use a waiver similar to what
the president used in tulsa a couple of
weeks ago when he had that rally
that that included
acknowledging
the risk of catching the coronavirus now
look
i i don't know that waiver is the right
term because unless you're signing away
your rights in the legal documents it's
not a waiver per se what it really is is
an acknowledgement of the risk lest
there be any confusion or doubt and
really i don't even think you need it in
this climate who's gonna go to a game
get coveted 19
and then say i got this game i got this
virus got this disease at a football
game and i had no idea that can happen
right
everybody knows the risk at this point
now
the the real potential liability comes
from
what steps if any will be taken to try
to minimize the spread will be a mandate
that everyone must wear masks will you
be ejected from the venue if you don't
have a mask on will there be six feet of
separation among the seats how far does
the nfl go that way or do they just say
this is what we're doing
mask wearing isn't mandatory seating is
going to be as it always is you assume
all risks if you use
this and we encourage you if you have
any doubt whatsoever don't buy the
ticket don't come to the game period so
look again
waiver is a little bit misleading
because i think that implies that
someone is actually signing their name
to a document that waves legal rights
this isn't about waiving legal rights so
much as it's about defeating those legal
rights by making it 100 clear that
everybody knows what they're getting
into and again who on the face of earth
right now who in this country right now
would be able to say they don't know
about the risk of getting the
coronavirus and developing covet 19 by
going to something like a sporting event
or any other large gathering
speaking of legalities
i saw recently that baseball is not
going to disclose when players are on
the covet 19 list this separate list
they've created for parking players who
otherwise would be on the roster while
they go through the process of having
the virus leave their system they're not
going to announce who's on it
people are just going to have to figure
it out hey where's jim jim's not here he
must be on the covet 19 list there's no
other explanation he's not on the dl
he's not deciding to launch his own mini
strike
he's not here
there's no other explanation for why
he's not here so he must be on the cove
at 19 unless it's kind of ridiculous
again people treat this disease like
it's
it's got a stigma it doesn't have a
stigma why do we think it has a stigma
the only thing that has a stigma is if
you did something stupid to get it like
go to a bar without a mask on engage in
behavior you should be engaging it
that's the stigma you were dumb it's
avoidable and you didn't avoid it but
the idea they're not gonna tell people
who has it you're just gonna have to
figure it out
oh he's not here tonight
see i think that gets into the whole
integrity of the game from the
standpoint of gambling perspective
you're not going to find out ahead of
time
think about that and football can't do
that well
what i mean what are you going to do you
have an injury report before every game
questionable doubtful out
questionable knee doubtful
ankle out
hip whatever
the the one guy who doesn't have a
designation
you don't have a designation oh that's
the covet guy it's stupid it's just
stupid it's impractical and maybe major
league baseball just agreed to it
because they said who cares i mean
people are going to figure it out but
the problem is
when guys show up for that first game or
don't show up for that first game that
they're on the covet 19 list if you've
got people who have weighed your hard
earned money on the outcome of that game
and thought so-and-so was going to be
there now all of a sudden he's not you
just like to think that there will be
some advanced notice that the player
won't be there and regardless of whether
or not they disclose the reason i think
it's incumbent on baseball and also
football in the other sport in this
current climate of of a proliferated
legalization of gambling that somebody
will
make it clear that the player isn't
going to be there even if they don't say
why he's not going to be there but i
just don't like that because it treats
this disease like it's some sort of a
secret it's not a secret and given the
fact that it is something that can
spread i think the more we know about
who has it
the the greater
awareness people have about who to
interact with who to go around it's just
a situation where more knowledge is
better than less knowledge it's not like
we're going to run into some baseball
star somewhere and say oh i'm staying
away from you you're on the kobe 19 list
i just think the idea and the attitude
that it should be treated with secrecy
is unfortunate because it can trickle
down and other people can say well yeah
i'm not telling anybody when i have it
either if baseball's not telling anybody
who has it why should i tell anybody if
i have it i'm not telling anybody i'm
not sharing this information and then
the whole system potentially breaks down
all right one last topic for today
the
concept of opting out and this is part
of what
the nfl and the nfl players association
inevitably is currently discussing and
they need to get it worked out sooner
rather than later on thursday players
are going to be talking about these
issues at some point a deal needs to be
done between the league and the union or
you can't have training camp and maybe
in this deadline driven sport
they take it right up to july 28
before they have an agreement but one
facet of this agreement must be
that players retain the right to tap out
if they decide they don't feel safe in
any environment
their locker room
practice
field
game whatever the case may be
now i think the nfl will probably push
for
a speak now or forever hold your peace
approach where before the start of
training camp
you have to say you're in or you're out
i haven't heard that
but it wouldn't surprise me if the
league doesn't push for that
that seems to be an obvious position the
nfl would want we want to know at the
outset who's in who's out i don't think
that's good enough because for the
players who are showing up on july 28th
they don't know what to expect they
don't know what it's going to look like
they don't know how it's going to feel
do you really want a guy who is on the
team in the locker room on the field who
develops a realistic fear
a realistic distress and concern
over the way things are being handled if
he doesn't feel safe in that environment
why are you requiring him to stay in
that environment so i think that players
need to have the power
at any time this season whenever they
see fit to say i'm out
and then i think they need to have a
period of time after that
where they can say
i'm back in i don't think it should be a
revolving door
where you can say i'm out on october 10
i'm back in on october 17. i'm out again
on october 31 i'll let you know if i'm
coming back before thanksgiving
there needs to be
a procedure that's fair
and maybe you only get
one
leave and return
and then if you leave the second time
you can't come back these are all things
that need to be hammered out
and
it's unavoidable
and let's be realistic i don't want to
be cynical here i want to be realistic
based upon what i've learned over the
past 20 years of covering the sport
i feel like
some players may be tempted
to use the opportunity to opt out
as a way to maybe
get a better contract
for reasons unrelated to the coronavirus
now
let me say this
there could be a player who says you
know what i feel like i'm underpaid i'm
going to threaten to not play this year
even though i have a contract and i
can't hold out because i'd be fine 50
000 a day and i'd have other penalties
if i hold out i give up my salary i tap
out
i don't play because of the coronavirus
and if they want me to play well they
better they better you know give me what
i want financially and then i will not
exercise my right to tap out but there
will be some players
who look at this as a financial
proposition
how much is enough to get you to assume
that risk
see there's been talk about the players
possibly taking less this year
give backs under the
salaries that are paid out to the
players that bubbled up a few weeks ago
via nfl media i think it was kind of a
trial balloon that was being floated to
see how the fans would react see how the
union would react
look if i'm a player
and i'm fully cognizant of the risks
that i already am assuming in a normal
year and now
in 2020 i'm gonna have this additional
stress this additional burden this
additional risk that i'm going to be
made ill that i'm going to expose my
family members to illness and
potentially to death depending upon
their risk factors
i'm tempted to say you should pay me
more
to do this
you should eat into your profit margin
to do this because you owner of the team
will not be taking these same risks you
owner of the team will all times be
protected by whatever
device you have created to seclude
yourself from everyone else
just staying home
being in a box that is fully and
completely ventilated with no one else
in there on game day i don't know how
many owners will even go to the stadium
on game day the bottom line is the risks
are fundamentally different
and so
if you do create a system that allows
players to opt out
the reality is you introduce a new
factor for negotiation to get players to
not opt out
and you've got two categories the player
who
legitimately looks at this and says
for
1.5 million dollars this year it's not
worth it
if you want to
make it more worth it
i'll consider it
but all things considered here with all
the factors balancing
given what you're paying me
i'd rather not play
oh
you're paying me more than what i'm due
to make well now it's starting to
balance out
and then at some point
you tip the scale in the direction of
the guy saying i'll do it that's that's
that's reality
and the other reality is there will be
guys who aren't worried about the virus
at all but see it as an opportunity with
the consultation of their agents who i
guarantee you will be thinking through
these issues
and will give us every reason to be as
cynical as we can be about this there
will be agents
who tell a guy hey look i know you don't
care about the virus but maybe you
should well what do you mean i don't
care about i'm not worried about it i'm
healthy i'm young
you're living with me who are at risk
maybe you should maybe you want to think
this through a little bit more there
before you make a final decision
maybe maybe there's a way
that we can play this
to get you a better contract to get you
an extension to get you whatever look at
chris jones right
chris jones can say i'm not comfortable
playing this year under the franchise
tag given the risks of playing i'm a big
guy i don't know his bmi is but anybody
with a bmi of over 30
is in a position where there's a
heightened risk and if you've ever seen
one of those bmi charts
there's a lot of people who are
in the upper 20s and 30s who you
wouldn't think are that high on the on
the overall scale
but
it
that to me is a very real factor in
these negotiations and that's what takes
it from the negotiations between the
players
and the league collectively and makes it
an individualized thing that can just go
off the rails you could have a rash of
players you could have a stampede of
players who are saying
i'm not playing this year unless you
give me more whether it's because they
want more to offset the risk of playing
in a pandemic or they just want more
because they want more anyway and they
could care less about the risk they just
see this as an opportunity to get more
it's a fascinating dynamic and it's
another reason why
no matter how hard i try to make myself
optimistic about this i look at these
issues i look at this circumstance i pay
close attention to the news
and i like ronnie harrison on
yesterday's pftpm like bill cower in
comments he made to ed bouchette of the
athletic i just don't know how they're
gonna pull this off
and i feel like the attitude in the
approach is
let's just see how it goes
and i feel like that
attitude
that strategy
is not a winning strategy
not that there's a better one
but the nfl had the benefit of a
significant head start here
and i don't know that the nfl has made
full use of its head start
and i'm not surprised we say it all the
time the nfl is not proactive the nfl is
reactive and i think we're going to see
a lot of reacting
in july and august and the problem is
when it's time to react when it's time
to pivot to plan b plan c plan d plan e
plan f
part of what we're going to hear is well
that plan would have worked
if that would have been plan a
and because we didn't
plan for that
from march and just assumed plan a would
work
plan b plan c plan d plan whatever isn't
going to be feasible isn't going to be
practical and the primary example there
is the bubble concept there's no way in
hell they're gonna throw a bubble
together on the fly
so could we see the same thing we've
seen from other sports
maybe it does get postponed
maybe we do have a late february super
bowl maybe we have a march april or may
super bowl and then when in the hell do
you start the next season
a lot of questions a lot of issues a lot
of basis for realistic concern and not a
lot of information
allowing anyone who pays attention to
the sport on a regular basis to come to
the conclusion
that they have a plan that will work
again
this does not come from the perspective
of someone who is rooting against
football i am very much rooting for
football to happen
but i'm also very realistic and i'm
concerned that the nfl has not been
as prudent as careful and as proactive
as it needs to be to come up with a plan
that will work to anticipate every
hurdle jc tretter the union president
said recently what i've been saying for
weeks
every time there's a question that's
answered three more questions come up he
said three i've said five let's split
the difference and call it four either
way this snowball grows and grows and
grows and it quickly could be an
avalanche and it makes me wonder
how could this have been avoided with
better planning
with better foresight
and with a greater appreciation of the
challenge the nfl is facing and
should we be surprised
if the most popular sport in america
ends up behaving just like the american
government has behaved the past four
months i guess we shouldn't be i guess
that's all we can expect from the best
that we have to offer in this country is
no planning
is no creative thought no foresight no
proactivity
and in the end it may be no football
that's it for today's pft pm we'll be
back tomorrow with all the latest news
and insights and analysis until then
check us out around the clock of
profootballtalk.com have a great day
stay safe and wear a mask
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports